grab some champagne and relax with a few
cigars because we have david fincher's
latest biopic about the man who wrote
one of the most critically acclaimed
films of all time
citizen kane in this video we'll be
going over how writer herman j
mankowitz made this american classic his
relationship with orson welles
and how newspaper tycoon william
randolph hearst also known as tywin
lannister
tried to bury the picture from ever
being distributed but before we get into
all these cool details make sure to like
and subscribe because here we
go as the beginning of bank states
citizen kane would never have been made
if it weren't for an ambitious young
storyteller named orson welles who at
the time was a huge name in radio
you might remember him as the guy who
voiced and directed the war of the
world's radio broadcast which was so
realistic it caused widespread panic
when people thought
aliens were actually invading incredible
as it may seem both the observations of
science and the evidence of our eyes
lead to the inescapable assumption that
those strange beings who landed in the
jersey farmlands tonight
are the vanguard of an invading army
from the planet mars believe it or not
citizen kane was the third movie wells
pitched to rko
after his first two ideas were rejected
he enlisted the help of mink who at the
time had been writing some
radio plays for him wells himself had
been busy doing test screening for an
adaptation of joseph conrad's heart of
darkness which was to be his first film
shot entirely in long shots and told
from a first-person perspective but the
venture was deemed too costly and was
dropped
paving the way for citizen kane mank did
end up getting in a car crash with
fellow screenwriter tommy phillips
breaking his leg in three places
but it wouldn't be until three months
later that he'd start writing citizen
kane in order to understand
how that movie came to be we have to
understand the man behind it as many
aspects of hermann mankowitz's personal
life
bleed into the script although we're
with mank for only two hours during the
course of this film we certainly do get
an impression of who he was
you cannot capture a man's entire life
in two hours all you can hope is to
leave the impression the one this same
is true of
charles foster kane the fictitious
newspaper tycoon based off real-life
media magnate william randolph hearst
whom mank had been a part of his inner
circle he became involved with hearst
through charles lederer a child prodigy
who went to college at the age of 13
and whom mank invited to hollywood to
make it big in the pictures
at the time movies were transitioning
out of the silent era and now films
needed writers more than ever
little did mank know that his
relationship with hearst and his
mistress marion davies would become the
basis for his greatest work yet
the question is why would mink throw his
friends under the bus
and write a movie that portrays them as
sad pathetic creatures
and this is what the film mank tries to
get at first we see how mank is trying
to create something that lasts
a work that will stand out as his
masterpiece as he drunkenly tells his
wife one night
the last time what what years
herman i should have done something by
now
this is perhaps why he so vehemently
fights for his writing credit at the end
of the film
an argument with orson welles that
results in wells smashing the place up
and inspiring this
iconic scene from citizen kane
[Music]
at the time mink was out of work having
burned bridges with people like louis b
mayer the studio head of mgm
so he agreed with orson not to take a
writing credit in the film's climax mank
fights for this credit even willing to
be sued and lose his money on the
project
just for the chance that his name will
appear on it he knows this is his best
work
and he wants to fight for what is right
some have argued that max's script is an
attack on hearst for having been ousted
out of his inner circle hearst took a
liking to mank early on
often inviting him to his lavish estate
named san simeon which
would become the inspiration for charles
keynes xanadu
in the film this falling out with hearst
ends with mank outlining the plot to
citizen kane
masked as a modern day retelling of don
quixote with hearst playing the part of
the titular hero himself he ends up
making such a fool of himself he pukes
and a fool he thinks he
is he's referred to as a court jester
more than twice in the film and he asks
his wife four times in the movie why
she's still with him even though he
thinks he's a lousy drunk
he even calls her poor sarah for being
married to him
this outburst was a long time in the
making he had gotten to know hearst
personally and seen how his power had
manipulated the population
this is never more evident than in the
election between democratic socialist
upton sinclair and republican frank
miriam off the heels of the great
depression the established elite feared
sinclair who ran on a campaign of ending
poverty
and making the rich pay their fair share
so they used fear tactics and
manipulation via the media to influence
voters
mink talks to his wife about how he
knows one of the voice actors portraying
an anti-sinclair widow on the radio was
actually an actress or how his director
friend shelly metcalf was hired to
create anti-sinclair propaganda which
saw a fake russian saying how he's going
to vote for
comrade sinclair and fake footage of
homeless people coming off the trains in
droves
shelley would later go on to kill
himself blaming himself for being part
of sinclair's loss
mink even tries to get mary and davies
to go back to irving thalberg then head
of production at mgm
to pull the adds but she refuses saying
she's already made her grand exit
something mank can't help but laugh at
the absurdity
one can't help but notice the symbolism
of marion being traded to another studio
a commodity like one of the sets paraded
out with her bonus points if you saw
that sinclair here is played by bill nye
the science guy
for mank people like hurst and louis
mayer are without ideals they have no
moral compass
it's perhaps studio head louis mayer who
best personifies this
he cuts his workers pay in half while he
keeps his huge salary even swaying his
workers to cheer for him after cutting
their wages for him it's all an act
how'd they do man
he even fakes crying at irving
thalberg's funeral throwing his
handkerchief out the window after
knowing he no longer needs it in public
it's hearst however who mank has more
disdain for because unlike
mayor hearst once held progressive
ideals he believed in helping the poor
in a more fair distribution of wealth
now however he's turned his back on
those ideals in favor of greed and
personal gain
just like how charles foster cain does
in citizen kane kane is depicted as an
idealist
even printing on the front page of his
first paper a declaration of principles
stating that his paper will have no
special interest
and that he will champion the rights of
its readers as human beings by the end
of the film kane's best friend mails him
back this declaration which kane
promptly rips apart
hearst too has turned away from his
ideals
in the end however mank's outburst at
the party was not out of anger but out
of sorrow
what i said was more sorrow than
inaugurally
he knows how hearst grew up unloved the
thing you got
so right in your script was how
lonely he'd been as a boy that's why
hearst ran for political office to get
that feeling of being love
in citizen kane kane too runs for office
wanting the love of the people something
he never got from his parents as a child
in fact in citizen kane his real parents
essentially sign him away
don't you think i'd better meet the boy
i've got his trunk all packed
i've had it packed for a week now
speaking of citizen kane is kane's
mistress
susan alexander who will later become
his second wife she's based off marion
davies a film star and her
real-life mistress depicted in the film
by amanda siffried in citizen kane she's
depicted as a terrible opera star who
kane uses his power and pull in the
media
to give her good reviews and headline
shows the same is said of marion and
hearst in real life
using his power and connections with
studio heads to get marion lead roles
we see that mink and marion have a warm
platonic relationship he knows that
she's not happy in this relationship
even catching her outside drinking
booze she's kept hidden in real life
like in citizen kane
marion would become increasingly
isolated at san simeon
turning to alcoholism and lamenting her
loneliness
mank asks her nephew charles to give her
a copy of his script knowing full well
that the opera singer in his story
is based off marion perhaps if marion
read the script she'll see what her life
has become
but it's charles that warns mank whether
this cure he's proposed is better than
the disease itself
and mank is warned not to go through
with the movie by three of his close
friends
going up against william randolph hearst
is no walk in the park
charles doesn't want him to go through
the picture as he sees it as a betrayal
to his aunt
are you hoping i might absolve you with
such a personal betrayal
his brother joe warns him that if he
goes through with it he'll likely never
work again
you pick a fight with willy you are
finished
mayor can't save you nobody can and
marion doesn't want him to do it because
how it will make hurst look mank doesn't
give in unlike the other characters we
see in the movie he has ideals he has
principles he's fighting for something
and in this way he's almost like that
young
charles foster kane during the dinner
scene mank talks about how his main
character will look into the mirror and
see his younger self
a reminder of the idealistic young
person he turned his back on
he smashes it in anger the final
metaphorical blow to his youth much like
how in citizen kane the smashing of the
snow globe represents the death of
cain's youth
the time where he was most happy it's
actually the death of two things his
life and of his idealism
destroying in the process not one man
but two it's no wonder that the guests
at hearst's mansion are dressed up in
circus attire their lives are a circus
wild hilarious sad
and often out of control mank is
escorted off hearst's property by the
man himself but not before being told
the parable of the organ grinder's
monkey a story of how a monkey who
thinks himself in control
is forced to perform for his street
peddler owner every day
in this parable mank is the monkey and
hearst is the owner
it's a story often used to describe the
act of one who does the bidding for
someone much more powerful
make even refers to himself as hearse
organ grinder monkey when talking to
houseman
are you familiar with the parable of the
organ grinders
monkey mank himself is a deeply flawed
character an
alcoholic and chronic gambler but that's
not to say flawed characters can't be
good people
rita finds that he sponsored hundreds of
german refugees his parents having been
immigrants from germany themselves he's
a man of principle even though
alcoholism consumed him a disease which
would ultimately take his life at the
age of 55. when citizen kane was
ultimately released in 1941
it was a box office flop largely due to
a giant
campaign by william randolph hearst who
didn't allow any advertisement for the
film and his papers and who also
threatened theaters who showed it with
libel it was however nominated for all
nine categories the oscars had in 1942
winning best original screenplay wells
and mank would not go on to collaborate
after their success
and at the end of the film mank is asked
why wells got a credit for the film in
the first place
mink says it's because of quote
hollywood magic but orson claims he
wrote his own draft then combined it
with mankowitz's to create somewhat of a
hybrid he's quoted as saying
i used what i wanted of manx and rightly
or wrongly kept what i liked of my own
so i leave it up to you to decide
whether or not he should have received a
credit overall mank isn't just a story
about the making of citizen kane
it's the story of how a story comes to
be how real life can influence what we
tell and why we want to tell it but i
want to hear what you thought of the
movie below
thanks for watching everyone while
you're here why not like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you